hey welcome back to new rockstars i'm
eric voss here with jessica clements
jessica clemens and as you can see we
are outside of the uh famous chinese
theater here in hollywood california we
just saw thor love and thunder and uh we
just had to just record our instant
reactions this isn't even going to be a
review this these our thoughts are not
organized because we had so many
feelings coming out of this movie and we
really just wanted to give you guys just
a very vague impression of how to
emotionally calibrate yourself before
you see this movie i'll say this is my
talk
this is my talk this is your song this
is my top this is wow and again i'm not
trying to get reactions or reviews but
here's here's one thing i will say
uh jess as the credits rolled you turned
over to me and what did you see oh i
can't say anything what did i do what
did i say what do you see i was sobbing
at the end oh no he was shaking i was
sobbing i don't i've never cried at a
marvel movie
um
yeah i i
produce very strong uh feelings i mean
here's what i will say throughout the
film i found myself
bobbing my head rocking out to the
soundtrack i found myself cheering i
found myself laughing i think this was
funny or even then thor ragnarok
the [ __ ] the bits really got me
really got me um this is a film that is
gonna have a lot of people talking about
uh the implications for everything in
the in the marvel cinematic universe i i
think it introduces some characters no
i'm not even gonna go i can't even
that's the hard part but it's so good
yeah it's uh it's
guys i i had a blast i mean this like
taiko with t2 really accomplished
something amazing here obviously we're
not going to get any spoilers any kind
of specific thoughts because
we obviously wouldn't want to spoil
anything for you but like it is a
it's a film that uh will just make you
believe again in so many things it's
just so good it's so moving in every
direction here's what i will say
bring someone you love
with you and obviously i love jess uh
bring someone you love i can't wait to
go see this with with kelly my fiancee
at least three more times i can say that
confidently without no joke i'm probably
gonna see like one too much if if you
have parents bring them if you have kids
bring them if you have siblings bring
them might be the most romantic mcu film
because it it just asks some really deep
thoughts about what it means to love uh
what it means to have someone important
to you like
and how that can give your life so much
meaning
and purpose
uh
it's the one right it's the most
thorough
and it just tells it's just a story
about this it's it's
the most like norse of the four movies
in some ways like it must be the most
asgardian this definitely is because i
don't think about it at all and then
this movie has you thinking about it a
lot it makes me want to go back and read
every aspect
of every norse book i know every and i
don't know so and you know what i really
appreciated about this one is it's and
and ragnarok did this too it's not the
kind of movie where like
doctor stranger multiverse madness for
comparison for people who didn't know
marvel lore or understand like the rainy
verse or or sam raimi tropes i think i
mean we love those things but i think a
lot of people will go into those movies
feeling like i didn't get all the
references i needed my i needed my new
rockstar subscriber to sit next to me to
explain everything this movie was not
that i think anybody will be able to go
into this movie and just completely
appreciate it and understand it and
enjoy themselves
the action there's so many like
yes
beatdowns
it's all so hard to not talk about it
and there's so much story in it to for
you to have to go into oh baby
i have i can't show you uh this part of
it but like notes i was writing notes
the entire time he ripped a notebook
i ripped a notebook in half because
otherwise it wouldn't fit in my pocket i
need my reporter's notebook to do that
you know it's funny we were sitting with
there's a couple other um uh friends of
the channel who came to the screen
real rejects is somewhere oh yeah there
we see greg
those goofballs
already reacting to our reaction look at
them go he's rocking the uh the
strongest avenger hat though
guys it was crazy i mean there are uh uh
look it's a marvel movie there's some
cameos for war but it's not the kind of
movie that like is gonna be if you
happen to see any leaks or spoilers out
there we will not be part of it but if
you happen to the movie's not gonna be
ruined all right like this definitely
it's such a full experience it's so much
to it too so it's like one spoiler is
not even close to spoiling the movie
there's so much of it taika with tt
really outdid himself both as a director
and a co-writer in the script and also
as court what a great korg film like
cork was just kind of a glorified cameo
in ragnarok here this is like cord gets
a full article and cork is every single
person gets an article honestly and
there's
oh absolutely nothing is wasted in this
movie no one feels like they're done
dirty this is like korg's story in a lot
of ways it feels like korg is telling us
this story uh we want to thank the whole
creative team for putting this together
yeah that does come i want to do this
again and probably not cry in front of a
lot of people that i admire like real
rejects oh yeah i don't want anyone to
see me cry ever again
guys i was crying i i want to tell you
specifically why i was great it's not
what you think i'll just tell you you're
probably thinking like what what made
eric cry you don't know me well enough
to know why i was crying i want to say
that things i've never talked about on
the new rockstars channel are the reason
that i was crying and he teared up at
the very beginning so that's awesome i
also teared up at the very beginning
there's so much that was not spoiled in
trailers at all they did a really good
job cutting trailers i'm the number one
person if you watch the break room
literally being like i can't watch any
more clips i'm tired of being spoiled
yeah they started to in more recent if
you can help it avoid the more recent tv
spots that have come out
and i think you're probably better off
avoiding that but like even if you do
trust me the biggest things that
happened in this movie
not a single frame of them are in the
trailers of the marketing material they
did a really really good job marketing
this movie hats off hats off to marvel
studios big things to come in the mcu
and there's gonna be a lot to talk about
coming out of this movie this is my
number one this is my number one this is
my number one of this year and number
one overall it's too early for me to
know how to rank it too early for me
that's how i know it's my one i can't
wait to talk about it it's so hard to
not talk about it it was just i like i'm
silly i like fun and i like
i like feeling that feeling and i think
this is my number one wow wow
i don't know if it's the landing i don't
know if it's the endings but oh yeah
yeah there's there's more to come
there's absolutely more to come
and edit out of that we're gonna cut out
that last sentence you can't know you'll
have to wait to see our review in our
breakdown but look at that look at that
sign back there fall far from trees
[Laughter]
what is love
green if not grief
what if what is persevering if not grief
loving
it doesn't seem fair
hey thank you so much for watching this
reaction a more organized thoughtful
review is coming to the channel just in
the week of the movie and then of course
we'll have our breakdown we'll have our
instant reactions we'll do a whole bunch
of explainer videos because there's
going to be a lot to talk about thank
you so much for watching be sure to
subscribe to rockstars follow me at ea
boss follow jessica at lulu underscore
clemens follow new rocks i support our
merch top you want to look like real
rejects you want that hat you want to
wear it at premier league go to epic
hero shopping
[Laughter]
[Music]
you